bom-dia família ted é uma família eu me
sinto realmente em casa é um prazer
estar com vocês no lugar em que eu sei
que quase ninguém vai manchar doida eu
vim conversar com vocês sobre luto não
dava pra fazer isso de forma leve fiz
meu máximo e ao invés de contar uma
história minha da minha vida outras
pessoas contaram isso eu gostaria de
contar histórias que eu ouvi as 15 anos
que eu atendo pacientes enlutadas
pessoas que perderam seus entes queridos
e em nome dessas pessoas que eu falo
hoje dedico a minha apresentação eu
gostaria que vocês também a enxergassem
e me enxergasse apenas como uma porta
voz
tá bom prometo que vou falar sobre luto
mas antes disso eu queria contar uma
experiência que eu tive é fantástica
para mim foi fantástico não sou tão
velho
mas eu descobri testes do facebook
viciei o primeiro que eu fiz foi esse
que estão vendo aí né se fosse uma
princesa da disney que princesa seria
wells a essa é o celso né
me empolguei né continue fazendo da
cerveja achei que deu até dá pra confiar
foi fazendo 1 a 0 aí comecei a fazer que
vilã eu seria esse eu não tenho coragem
de publicar aqui biscoito você seria meu
deu cook não sei porque quando eu vi já
estava fazendo até aquele do éter bêbado
já fizeram isso e aí ele disse que se eu
estiver com fome e ouvir uma psicopata
verdade está certo mas aí eu fiquei
perguntando me perguntando o seguinte
por que que a gente investe tempo da
nossa vida para fazer teste no facebook
e publicar o resultado
tem gente que vota assim se eu fosse um
animal eu seria uma iguana para essa
foto aí quando você curte coraçãozinho
vai fazer o quê
mas aí eu tentando entender isso e sou
psicóloga vocês sabem meu trabalho é me
entender entender os outros e o mundo
todo o tempo todo fazendo isso eu pensei
o seguinte o que a gente faz esses
testes porque a gente está com muita
dificuldade em saber quem a gente é ea
gente precisa de um parâmetro o teste do
facebook dá um parâmetro é algo que diz
olha você é isso
isso te representa ea gente está o tempo
todo buscando uma âncora de identidade
os valores que nos definiu na nossa
sociedade mais tradicional estão ficando
para trás a gente está buscando saber
cada vez mais quem a gente é ea gente
tem pouco a para a religião grandes
tradições rituais antigos vêm se
perdendo na sociedade moderna ea gente
busca essas coisas
junto com essas coisas de busca
a ciência conhece deve ser cinco os
médicos se o dsm 5 manual diagnóstico de
transtornos mentais manual diagnóstico e
estatístico de transtornos mentais é
editado pela associação de psiquiatria
americana
uma amiga me mandou isso aí disse que
era a minha cara livre um livro de mil
páginas com todos os transtornos mentais
aí eu faço que nem 60 minutos de
sabedoria cada dia há uma página
quando não quando não encontra encontra
alguém diagnóstico alguém é divertir
muito bem
o fato é que se esse dsm ele está na sua
5ª número 5 o primeiro é de 1952 ele
tinha 100 páginas pessoal
o primeiro tinha 100 páginas e assim
eles vão crescendo talvez um militar
os cinco têm mil para estamos ficando
doido muito dor e agora a gente vai
fazer um exercício pessoal da convido
vocês a se virarem para o colega da
direita ora pessoal ira não o da direita
vira pra vocês vão fazer o par
ó horas é agora vocês vão olhar
profundamente no olho da pessoa
o fundo ou ir ao fundo agora olhando
fundo
qual é
bom muito bom agora vocês vão ter que
decidir entre vocês dois
quem é o normal
segundo essa pesquisa de harvard não é
qualquer um e harvard
um em cada dois americanos vai
desenvolver um transtorno psiquiátrico
ao longo da vida é tarde
o brasileiro fica atrás não tá aí ó
agente variar entre uma estatística de
20 56%
ao longo da vida tá todo mundo doido
mesmo os padrões estão se ampliando
muito o que a gente vê é que o
crescimento do tsm é uma inflação de
agnóstica muitos diagnósticos tudo a
doença
a gente compra o tomate na segunda
porque faz bem no domingo já cansa
comprovou na terça na segunda não pode
colesterol alto e por isso é bom
colesterol
a gente fica doido né então a gente tá
tá assistindo um mapeamento ampliação
dos padrões de comportamento qualquer um
de nós se abriu 10 m vai achar alguma
coisa que vai identificar a gente está
patológica usando a vida a vida se não
for vivida dentro daquele padrão muito
rígido tudo a doença ea gente tem uma
série de diagnósticos transtorno
delirante de ciúme transtorno de
personalidade independente transtorno de
déficit de atenção e hiperatividade ou
sem ter actividade da pressão de todo
mundo não é
e aí a gente faz o que a gente faz a
velha terapia do remédio a gente não
quer sofrer a gente vai ocupar-se criada
o psicólogo ou para ambos
ou vai para a mesa do papa o fato é que
a gente não quer mais sofrer a gente não
aguenta nenhuma dor na unha
mas eo que dizer da tour que a gente
sente quando alguém que a gente ama
morre
se a gente não aguenta nem aquela dona
ruim vocês imaginam essa a gente não
fala sobre morte a gente não fala sobre
o luto e cada um de nós vamos ter
tivemos devemos ter
vamos ter várias perdas ao longo da vida
o jogo estava contando que depois da
doença dele preocupar em sair
ele teve um momento de virada na vida
dele
provavelmente ele encontrou a morte ali
a gente vai ter oportunidade de fazer
essa virada hoje sem necessariamente
perder ninguém e sem ter um outro real
amor a gente vai aprender através da
experiência de outras pessoas
das 10 coisas que eu vou dividir com
vocês aqui
a primeira é que nenhuma teoria é capaz
de explicar o luto
a gente tem muita teoria mais 15 será 18
anos tudo isso froid unb elizabeth
precoce pax jogador monte de gente fala
sobre o piloto mas a experiência de
viver o luto é única
só quem divide sabe o que é e cada um
ligado a seu modo
a teoria não é capaz de explicar porque
o luto é como o amor é uma experiência
viva o luto é um produto do seu lugar e
da sua cultura
para isso eu não vou usar uma fusão
experiência minha de tabela quando eu
tinha sete anos o meu pai me contou uma
história que ele enterrou o irmão uma
caixa de sapato
o irmão recém nascido naquela época no
sertão isso era comum as crianças eram
enterradas ali mesmo quintal quando eram
recém-nascidos nem batizavam nem
batizada 0
eu fiquei apavorada quando ele me contou
isso a primeira vez como que ele tinha
ele criança ele então com 78 o
irmãozinho dentro da caixa de sapato um
mato para enterrar o irmão e eu fiquei
meu deus q carro vai votar se eu morrer
17 anos cresceu a caixa de tv de sapato
na cabeça mas aquilo é aquilo mexeu
comigo
isso deve fazer 50 anos só ea nossa
visão de mostra completamente
frente a gente protege as crianças da
morte até onde dá a gente se protege da
morte até onde dá
e ela faz parte do nosso cotidiano é
parte da nossa vida
o luto não é doença
às vezes ele se manifesta no corpo dor
de cabeça dor de estômago moleza dores
musculares
a gente fica mais suscetível até gripe
sistema imunológico aparentemente fica
abalado
e a gente fica mais propenso a adoecer
mas o luto não é uma doença é uma reação
esperada e normal
a perda de alguém que a gente ama não é
depressão não é stress não é transtorno
de estresse pós traumático é luto luto é
esperado não é doença isso eu queria que
ficasse muito na cabeça de vocês hoje
quando vocês encontrarem alguém de luto
quando vocês mesmos estiverem de luto a
lembrem disso não é doença porque eu tô
falando isso
frisando pisando em repisando porque no
dsm 5 aquele aquele que eu mostrei pra
vocês têm sua luta é citado 130 vezes
horas associado a doenças como se
pudesse desencadear doenças mentais e o
pior
ele agora está numa categoria que é luto
transtorno do luto complexo persistente
ele está numa categoria para estudos
posteriores
então muito provavelmente se nada mudar
no próximo 10 m
o luto vai ser oficialmente uma doença
mental é sério é grave e que precisa
resgatar a vida e nesse sentido também a
morte de uma paciente me disse isso que
o luto
há teorias que dizem que o luto é feita
de fases primeiro aceitação depois a
raiva depois da depressão
depois há o recomeço então tem várias
fases
o luto não é uma corrida de fazer não é
uma corrida de obstáculos que você vai
terminar e vai ficar bom
ele parece muito mais como ela me disse
a montanha russa no escuro você tá bem e
de repente alguma coisa minúsculo faz
você lembrar daquela pessoa e você 10
uma queda vertiginosa e as pessoas que
estão à sua volta não entendem estava
bem estava trabalhando qualquer coisa um
cheiro um som uma roupa uma palavra tão
tudo é capaz de fazer você descer a
montanha russa baixo uma data
comemorativa natal dia das mães e dos
pais que venham aniversário da pessoa
aniversário de morte
enfim tem uma outra parceria em que
perdeu um bebê recém-nascido bebê ficou
vivo sete dias e faleceu
e ela ficou bem no outro dia ela foi
trabalhar seguiu a vida
dez anos depois de estar bem
ela acordou de madrugada achando que
estava tendo um ataque cardíaco do no
peito é a sensação de morte iminente
dificuldade de respirar já estava com o
segundo marido já não tinha mais filhos
nem associou uma coisa outro foi o
hospital fez todos os exames ela não
tinha nada que justificasse aquela
reação que ela teve e ela me disse
o luto bateu à minha porta dez anos
depois eu tive que abrir então se você
não viver
se você não se entregar e sentimento que
não é vergonhoso porque a sociedade que
a gente teve o tempo todo feliz todo
mundo feliz no facebook feliz toda hora
lindo tem gente da vontade excluído tão
feliz
eu excluo e quando meus amigos viajam
com a posterior digo olha vou excluir
temporariamente que eu não aguento ver
suas fotos enquanto o trabalho
então a sociedade quer que você seja
feliz e não tolera a tristeza mas a
tristeza é um sentimento humano precisa
servir se não naquele momento volta
depois em forma de sintoma em forma de
problemas de relacionamento
ele é muito importante para ser relegado
outra moça me disse
ela tinha viela tem 22 anos e perdeu o
marido ficou viúva aos 22
ela me disse que ela sente como se
tivesse um buraco negro no peito porque
um buraco negro buraco negro suba todas
as energias estão todas as energias dela
tão canalizados para aceitar essa perda
até tomar banho e alunos a é uma energia
que ela não tem pode surpreender
então às vezes a gente vê aquela pessoa
em alguns momentos num quarto escuro sem
condição de trabalhar sem condições de
tomar banho sem condição de se alimentar
ou de sair ou de fazer sala para a
visita as pessoas ficam atolados de do
isso acontece a gente nunca está
preparado para atender quem a gente ama
nunca então não dá para se preparar
dá pra preparar alguém pra perder alguém
a não ser que a gente ama me sabendo que
um dia pode perder isso não vai tornar a
pé mais fácil - fácil mas não dá não dá
para preparar ninguém pra perder ninguém
às vezes as pessoas acham que se
desligando a única forma de não sofrer é
não a mando
se você não ama você não perde mas se
você quer amar o preço a possibilidade
de perder cada um resolve entre aspas e
se resolve
o luto à sua maneira tem gente que faz
música poemas filmes belíssimos planta
jardim funda ongs ajuda outras pessoas
enfim cada um dá um sentido a sua pedra
nesse sentido é muito particular
resolveu o luto não é
é o que as pessoas dizem voltar ao
trabalho e amor à vida normal
o primeiro mês está todo mundo ali dando
ajuda depois já começa a te escuta vai
voltar
aliás abia a licença pra luta em no
máximo sete dias a licença de trabalho
nossa sociedade realmente não permite
que a gente vê isso de forma de forma
saudável e tem gente que não resolve
nunca a rainha vitória passou a vida
inteira no luto do marido
vestiu preto naquela época ficar de luto
era chique
o preto é chique por isso quando da
rainha vitória ela passou a vida inteira
esperando o marido ela voltava o prato
dele na mesa ela separava a roupa que
ele existe
todo dia ela resolveu dessa forma por
mais que a gente olhe e diga que aquilo
ali não é saudável
foi o que ela conseguiu fazer ea gente
precisa respeitar o que cada um consegue
fazer com a sua pena
isso já falamos o luto é o preço do amor
são duas faces da mesma moeda e ele o
luto a dor o sofrimento ele te obriga a
rever joão fez isso no barco ele reviu
valores não precisa de tanta coisa vou
levar tudo a mochila vou pegar minha
família e vou embora porque faz dá um
choque de realidade mas você pensar o
tanto de tempo que você gasta com coisas
que não são essenciais
então entrar em contato com a morte e
com a possibilidade de perder as pessoas
que você ama é transformador
você começa a vida passa teuto outro
sabor
outras cores outro sentido
isso aconteceu comigo há 18 anos atrás
não que eu tenha perdido ninguém mas eu
comecei a conviver com essas pessoas ea
simples convivência ouviu que elas me
diziam transformou a minha vida uma
coisa mais leve
uma coisa mais simples tem uma coisa de
dias
viver o dia a gente não tem ontem a
gente não tem amanhã a gente tem hoje
tratar com quem a gente ama e que eu
queria deixar pra vocês
é isso que a dor é o amor
são duas faces da mesma moeda a vida ea
morte também
só quem tenha morte na consciência
mesmo que não seja o tempo todo pensando
nela é capaz de viver em profundidade de
aproveitar a vida cada segundo
e é isso que eu espero que vocês façam o
que nós façamos um exercício diário ao
sair daqui brigado